welcome to data of is deaf talk I'm your
host - kasi developer advocate for data
studio in this video we'll talk about
that tab strip development environment
that you will use to create your own
community collector let's get started if
you're not already familiar with Google
Apps Script its development environment
may seem quite different from what
you're used to when you use Apps Script
you develop your code in a browser-based
code editor the code is a specialized
version of JavaScript and you don't have
to host your app as it lives and runs on
Google servers in the cloud we're not
going to go into too much detail about
Apps Script in this video we'll cover
just the basics to get you started with
building your own community character if
you're interested to learn more about
Apps Script you can check out the Apps
Script code map the link is in the
description below to start building your
own connector head over to the App
script development environment at strip
Google comm and start a new project an
app script project represents a
collection of files and resources
sometimes referred to simply as a script
in our video series we might use Apps
Script project connector code and script
interchangeably your project can contain
one or multiple JavaScript files the
project will also continually manifest a
special JSON file that contains certain
metadata about the script itself we'll
talk more about the manifest in a later
video
absolu provides services to help you
develop your app including cache service
clock service
property service and many other for
example the cache service allows you to
temporarily cache results for a
time-consuming operation the service
lets you cache data at public level
where the data can be accessed by all
users of your connector or a private
level where the data can be accessed
only for individual users there is even
a data studio app service that helps you
to build your own community connector
you can write your code execute it test
and debug all within the app script
environment without leaving your browser
however if you want to use your own
favorite IDE to develop your code that's
also possible then you'll need to use
clasp clasp is an open-source tool
separate from the app strips platform
tip lets you develop and manage app
strips project locally from your
terminal rather than the app scripts
editor you can also use your favorite
development tools like get when building
your connector with clasp the clasp code
lab provides a overview of all cast
features the link is in the description
if you want to try it out now let's say
you have built your connector when you
or some other user tries to use it data
studio will execute the connector code
on the user's behalf when a user uses a
connector for the first time they must
authorize the connector to act on their
behalf during this time the UI presents
a prompt to the user to start the
authorization flow for that connector
during this flow the UI tells the user
what the connector wants permission to
do for example if the connector is
fetching data from bigquery it will ask
for microscope during the authorization
you can read more about the OAuth
process and OAuth scopes at the link in
the description this overview of app
script should help you to get started
with building your own connector you can
always go to our developer site at
developers.google.com/plus to do for
more information if you like this video
stay tuned on the GCP channel for more
data studio content thanks for watching
[Applause]